okay so a lot of people so uh a lot of
people have been send my Jew fros
getting a little long so I think I'm
gonna cut my hair make a video out of it
I don't know what haircut to get I've
been seeing these videos on YouTube
where people are letting the person in
front of them decide what they eat so
I'm gonna let the person in front of me
decide what hair can I get
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm genuinely feeling really nervous
because haircuts are like one of the
scariest things for me I almost never
get good haircuts that's why I let it
grow out I just never want to cut my
hair and I really don't like short
haircuts I I feel like I never looked
good with like really short hair so if
the person before me has a really short
haircut that's gonna be Tara I don't
know how long it'll take my hair to grow
out and my biggest fear is that because
I act like I don't know what I'll be
able to do for auditions if I have
really short hair I won't be able to
style it or play different characters
and like I just won't have auditions for
like a couple months I don't I don't
know what's gonna happen I really hope
the person before me had longer hair so
I get extensions or something like that
and then just get an even bigger do fro
or like nice long Viking hair like what
if it's a completely different color
than what you're used to they can do
that they absolutely can do that
why am I doing this my hope for this is
that it turns into like a typical
BuzzFeed video we're like oh I did
something out of my comfort zone and I
grew what my prediction is that it's
gonna look terrible
hey Stevie I'm a barber and the East
Village I work at her already
nice what do you think my hair right now
I mean you're beautiful texture so I
should just keep it not news video I
don't know what so basically everyone
wants me to cut my hair and I don't know
what haircut to do so there's a trend on
YouTube where people are letting the
person running to decide what they eat
so I'm gonna like a person inform you
decide what haircut I get so whatever
the haircut you gave last isn't a
haircut I get okay oh my god cool I
think you're gonna like it
am I gonna like it you're gonna enjoy it
I didn't gonna know what it is while I
was happening no no you it's better if
you just wait for the end it'll be a
surprise for all of us all right let's
do it
energy new videos but like I'm just too
nervous to have energy right now I've
literally never got you know I always
get the same exact haircut which is just
like shorter sides longer on top okay
I've never gone short will say though
that they've had short hair for a long
time what if I like do short people have
to have like that that's good shaped
ends right what if my shapes bad can you
feel it is it a weird do I have a bad
shape look of a very nice occipital bone
yeah how long does it take for hair to
grow back on average average month on
top you have three almost four inches
baby Samoans yeah
Oh No
damn
[Music]
sieving over to your boss fun oh yeah I
did have a bald spot no like right here
I think what's on my man no no wait
you're taking it all off yeah you told
me to do the last circuit oh no oh my
god I look so young but also like I feel
like I could be in prison break or like
One Tree Hill you don't like that one
guy with short hair and once you're
bombing I was good-looking which is the
problem what's your mother gonna think I
don't know what's my girlfriend gonna
say but
[Music]
[Music]
like many folk remember some fun that we
do anymore yeah bass in your voice mouth
all right we did it
I got the cut thank you a day for
inspiring me to do this actually feel
really great we're gonna go to the
office see what people think you you
look good yeah hello that's stripe
oh yeah there's a strike Oh stripe is
you belong in like stranger things this
is this is the hair but are you happy
with it I I like the hair I think I will
definitely get rid of the mustache oh
look at this look and fresh my god what
the hell is that
hey you're brave dude you're brave guy I
wouldn't do it I don't dislike it at all
you do look like you should be wearing
like a police badge around your neck
nice fun
nice look like me yeah
cordyceps right now what is that one is
it a porn stash oh and this is my hair I
[Music]
thought I'd look like sexy and cool
[Music]
[Music]
like the
[Music]